コンビニよく行かれますよねええ本当によく行くと思うんですけれどもよく飲む飲み物
は何ですか
ん
コーラよくお口直しに食べるものなんですけど
グラスきゅあそうなんですよその2つの組み合わせてや一色だと思う
まあなかなかないんですよなぜか6とか知らないしていると思うけどあれって結構講習
なほしいって言って
ミントの香りがすごいんですよそれをコーラシュワシュワ感を合わせると
tech だヴァンガー
まあようやく白ですのリーク今月トーンなどもすごい話を持ってきててへブーツケアは
全部食べた後におローンとなぜか号泣何かが起きるんですよねそれを今日はと試して
もらおうかなと思ってやってまいりましたいいねた
極めて入れた何かあったよそうなんですけどメントスコーラ的なイメージだと勝手に
思っている私は
なるほどなぁ
あーないですねパペンってゆけでコーナーのプレス機は準備しました
通常のプレス権とは違って来最大量のミントなんですよもう
ブレスケア史上最大と言われてるやつなんでめちゃくちゃ強い
50つあります
これを通した時さあそこそこ入ってますねでもこれしかもう本当は構えないんですよ
本当だ水などのリボンと一緒に飲み込んでくださいって書いてあります極めて危険な気
がするな
1階の部屋するよ自殺って書いてるのに全部ということでしょ
終わるここはもう噛まずに飲むんですけど今回は全館でもらえます
館で全部食べてもらいますこれ
その後にの高難度不良はそれはもういやもう分かります乗った瞬間の感想いけない
やろーじゃなかっ後僕はもう何も知らないもう間近バスからのどんな昔やったことなん
で1000粒食べて来て見て焼いちゃう非常にきつかったことぜんぶつけ髪ます
[音楽]
さあ
ですねグッピクリスっぽく落ちた来た来た2弾ももう今で言えばすごい
いやーポピっの
me
あーさー僕しゃべれないんだよこれ
だめだめだめだとすればどんどん上がって食べたわけだ
入ったがハッピー by きゃいけまぜなんでなんでひろっち
うんセンター動画ありがねぇどうぞ
はぁ
[拍手]
ああああああ
あっはあっはあっ向けて仕込みティ
すごいすごいああ
お手
のど越しがギターと思うよ痛いアタリは来ません入ったいえば
[音楽]
フッチョバッハ痛いね2元論
ています
やばいば結構危険性から結構危険だ猫の心身発曲がってまっすぐくるぞ
待てよ飛ばなきゃですね
飲んじゃうとどっかはいって取っても損ジャンって音で結局なっちゃうっていう
繰り返しなんてこれは実はからくりでもんではぜひ行ったカッター進まず以降だと
嬉しいけど本当な処理んんだかねステップすごいたかったすごい
壮大感がすごかったので皆さん言いたいんで真似しないようにしてください
持った
[音楽]
乗鞍ん
me
ええええええ
teal
me
ana あああっ